[Música]
la administración de joe biden y kamala
harris comenzar a oír en las primeras
horas como presidente de eeuu el
mandatario firmará 15 acciones
ejecutivas que revertirán las políticas
adoptadas por el presidente saliente de
donald trump entre los decretos está el
regreso a la o ms y al acuerdo de parís
un plan migratorio y la suspensión de la
construcción del muro en la frontera con
mexico
joe biden tomará posición este día en
una de las ceremonias más artísticas de
los últimos tiempos en un contexto de
pandemia seguridad en washington con una
pandemia que deja más de 400.000 muertes
en el país y ante fuertes divisiones
políticas ya en la capital by de níjar y
su link dieron tributo a las víctimas
mortales que ha dejado el hobbit 19
donald trump horas antes de dejar su
mandato de un discurso de despedida de
la presidencia de eeuu en un vídeo de
casi 20 minutos se proclamó orgulloso de
su gobierno y otorgó 73 indultos y 70
conmutaciones entre ellos a su ex
estratega stick balón también suspendió
por 18 meses las deportaciones de
venezolanos
hola buenos días en américa latina y a
todos ustedes que nos siguen por la
señal de france 24 señalan a austria
sean bienvenidos este 20 de enero un
cambio de gobierno sin precedentes se
abre paso este día en eeuu la ceremonia
de investidura convertirá a joe biden en
el presidente número 46 y toma el poder
en circunstancias inéditas con una
pandemia que deja un alto costo humano y
económico una amenaza de seguridad un
país dividido y un presidente saliente
que enfrenta a un juicio en el senado
acusado de alentar una insurrección
la capital estadounidense se encuentra
blindada para el acto de inauguración
hasta 25 mil miembros de la guardia
nacional además de 2.750 efectivos del
pentágono velarán por la seguridad del
evento en la primera hora de su mandato
baiden firmará 15 órdenes ejecutivas que
revierten las políticas de donald trump
nuestro corresponsal en washington
cristóbal vázquez nos amplio más sobre
el tema más temprano
los saludo desde acá desde el capitolio
cerca muy cerca estamos de dónde va a
ser el evento de inauguración las
políticas a destacar son varias 15 que
firmarán las primeras obras una vez se
instale como presidente de eeuu en las
próximas 4 4 4 años las más importantes
lo que tiene que ver con el quabit es
una iniciativa que quiere avanzar el
presidente joe biden queremos nombrar a
alguien que esté reportando
constantemente los cambios y los avances
en esta materia después está daca que es
la acción diferida para jóvenes que
llegaron acá cuando eran niños
inmigrantes eso es un punto muy
importante teniendo en cuenta la lucha y
el sufrimiento de estos jóvenes por pues
en la incertidumbre que tuvieron durante
los cuatro años de donald trump y
también está pues que va a acabar con el
tema de la no permiso de entrada que
tenían los inmigrantes de países
musulmanes
también nos acompaña desde washington
mamen salam amén buenos dias baiden toma
hoy posesión en medio de un excepcional
dispositivo de seguridad que tiene
militarizada a la capital estadounidense
como están a esta hora los controles las
calles el national mall
buenos dias sadam pues como os podéis
imaginar se hasta ahora la seguridad era
máxima
mucho más recordaron con washington no
solamente están los traman o chen
también llegaron by the new wyden y su
esposa y también participará en el
evento de hoy las familias es
presidencia en un clinton llegaba
también a la formación de washington
tiene encontrarse uno de estos controles
de seguridad tiene mis espaldas es
prácticamente imposible todas las calles
están cerradas valladas y tomadas por
eso son militares por esos 25 mil
militares
eso es alan cinco veces más de los que
hay ahora mismo desplegados en irak y
afganistán para que se hagan una idea
hay 13 líneas de metro cerrada también
se se ha cerrado el famoso nacional
humor y se está investigando y
registrando a todo el mundo de manera
aleatoria incluso a esos 25 mil
militares que participarán en la
protección del evento todo a raíz de que
se haya descubierto que entre los
asaltantes del pasado 6 de enero el
capitolio había algunos seis veteranos y
agentes de la policía
ya esta extrema seguridad en washington
tras el asalto al capitolio se le añade
que el evento no tendrá tampoco público
por la pandemia mamen que ya deja más de
400.000 muertes en el país cuáles son
las medidas tomadas para prevenir los
contagios
si harán desde luego esta renovación de
la democracia se va a hacer en un clima
completamente enrarecido como decías
debido a esas medidas anti kobe de los
200.000 asistentes que suele haber en
una ceremonia de toma de posesión solo
va a haber mil personas fuera dentro del
capitolio fueron la calle la imagen
también va a ser muy diferente no va a
haber público esa plaza es en national
more que os comentaba que suele estar
lleno de cientos de miles de ciudadanos
que viajan hasta washington para seguir
de cerca este día tan importante hoy no
lo harán la alcaldesa de la ciudad ha
pedido a los estadounidenses que no
viajen hasta la capital en su lugar es
el national molestará decorado con más
de 191.000 banderas estadounidenses y
como podéis imaginar mascarilla
obligatoria el desfile se retransmitirá
de manera virtual y ese baile y baile
inaugural que suele haber para cerrar
este día pues se va a sustituir por un
programa de televisión de cerca de 90
minutos que estará presentado por el
actor tom hanks
muchas gracias más en sala por tu
reporte desde washington seguiremos
pendientes contigo del desarrollo de
esta jornada y ahora hablemos de donald
trump porque tal y como se esperaba y
siguiendo lo que es ya casi una
tradición el presidente saliente firmó
143 indultos y con mutaciones en sus
últimas obras al frente de la casa
blanca entre los más destacados figura y
steve van un antiguo estratega de donald
trump y hombre clave en su victoria
electoral en 2016
también aparecen elliott broidy un
conocido benefactor del partido
republicano y el ex alcalde de detroit
kwame kilpatrick condenado por
corrupción incluso el rapero lil wayne
está en esta larga lista
trump también firmó un amparo de
deportación de 18 meses para ciertos
venezolanos sin antecedentes penales que
se encuentran en la unión americana como
consecuencia de la crisis que vive el
país sudamericano
y ahora nos vamos a miami frente a
amaral hago la lujosa residencia de
donald trump ahí está nuestro
corresponsal anthony belchí antonio y
cómo es el dispositivo de seguridad para
la llegada del presidente saliente
así es que está muy buenos días talan
donald trump prometió que iba a
trasladar su residencia de nueva york-
aquí a florida y así ha sido hay un gran
despliegue de seguridad en los
alrededores de esta residencia de mar al
agua está previsto que en unas cuatro
horas aterricé el air force one que
habrá realizado ya el último viaje del
aún mandatario donald trump ejerciendo
su función de presidente después se
trasladará del aeropuerto de palma hasta
esta residencia que están aquí a mis
espaldas donald trump como ya comentaba
shaalan ultimado en estas últimas horas
ha firmado esas 143 indultos y
conmutaciones 73 indultos y 70 con
mutaciones y también esa orden ejecutiva
para paralizar a las deportaciones de
venezolanos o por 18 meses un guiño a
ese apoyo que ha recibido en sobre todo
en esta campaña electoral de la
comunidad venezolana que al menos le dio
el triunfo
en florida pero no consiguió revalidar
su poder en la casa blanca
muchas gracias tanto nivel sí por tu
reporte desde mar a lago florida
estaremos también pendientes con él y
con todos los corresponsales de france
24 porque aquí le tenemos una cobertura
especial en este día histórico de eeuu
desde las 11 ahora a bogotá quito y lima
un gran equipo de periodistas y
analistas estarán en directo durante la
jornada de la juramentación y el
discurso presidencial
y el gobierno de donald trump acusó a
china de cometer un genocidio contra la
etnia musulmana uigur en la región de
indian así lo señaló el secretario de
estado saliente mike pompeo antes de
dejar su cargo y en un momento de grave
deterioro de las relaciones entre las
dos potencias mundiales el gobierno
chino ha rechazado toda acusación y
afirma que los campos son centros de
formación profesionales destinados a
alejar a los musulmanes uigures del
terrorismo y del separatismo aurora vall
tiene los detalles
nuevo golpe a china por parte del
gobierno de champ en el último día de su
presidencia
eeuu ha establecido oficialmente que
china está cometiendo un genocidio
contra la etnia musulmana uigur en la
región de chillán en el oeste del país
asiático
estos actos son una afrenta para el
pueblo chino y para las naciones
civilizadas de todo el mundo la
república popular china y el partido
comunista de china deben rendir cuentas
el trato que reciben los figuras en
chillán ha sido también ampliamente
condenado por la comunidad internacional
pero se trata de la denuncia más dura
hasta ahora de cualquier gobierno contra
las políticas de china en esta región
esta declaración no desencadenará
medidas inmediatas contra china pero
tendría un fuerte impacto simbólico a
nivel internacional y podría llevar a
eeuu a imponer más sanciones contra
china bajo la nueva administración
bailén sexo feria pop
esa es una de esas cosas tenemos que
asegurarnos de que tampoco estamos
exportando tecnologías y herramientas
que podrían ser utilizadas para fomentar
su represión las ones se hacen por
ejemplo creo que deberíamos asegurarnos
de no importar productos hechos con
trabajo forzado es julian rifat el
gobierno chino ha rechazado toda
acusación de genocidio y violaciones de
los derechos humanos se enseñan afirma
que los campos de
educación construidos en las zonas son
centros de formación profesional
destinados a alejar los musulmanes
uigures del terrorismo y del separatismo
méxico argentina y brasil encabeza en el
número de vacunaciones contra el cob y
19 en américa latina argentina además
enviará un primer cargamento de dosis de
astrazéneca para empaquetar en méxico
mientras que brasil la vacuna de las
regiones remotas de la amazonía del otro
lado están los países como bolivia que
no han hecho compras y solo están
confiando en el mecanismo de la ms
kóvacs informada luís muñoz
argentina continúa con paso firme el
país empezó a inocular la segunda dosis
de la vacuna rusa sputnik son 300.000
para personal de salud además argentina
en su colaboración con méxico envió al
país azteca el principio activo de la
vacuna de astrazéneca para que sea
envasado y empaquetado esta hierba
involucra a un laboratorio extra en
argentina como ustedes recordarán que
produce el principio activo lo mandó a
méxico y aquí en méxico laboratorio
montas el llenado y envasado fidel y de
ahí se distribuye méxico y de toda
américa latina brasil también muestra su
potencial tras iniciar la inoculación de
la vacuna china sinovac el ejército se
mueve por tierra mar y aire hasta llegar
a la amazonas donde los antropólogos
habían avisado que el kobe 19 ponía en
peligro formas de vida ancestrales
la vacunación es muy importante para
toda nuestra comunidad indígena para
todos los aldeanos era esto lo que
estábamos esperando pero el ritmo no
avanza igual en toda américa latina
colombia en pleno pico de la pandemia
por el momento sólo puede mostrar
almacenes para albergar 50 millones de
vacunas hasta menos 80 grados
centígrados el país cuenta con más de 3
mil contenedores portátiles que
permitirán llegar a las zonas más
remotas ya podemos decir a los
colombianos ya quienes habitan el
territorio colombiano y no nacionales
que por supuesto estamos preparados para
el recibo de las vacunas y su aplicación
la región continúa luchando por
conseguir unas vacunas que están en
manos de los países más ricos mientras
los sistemas de salud continúan al
límite ante los rebrotes causados por la
pandemia de kobe 19 y en el tercer
episodio de nuestra serie sobre cómo
avanza la vacunación en francia
hablaremos de las estrictas condiciones
de conservación de las dosis de los
laboratorios facer y variante del tipo a
rn concretamente la cadena de frío debe
mantenerse durante todas las etapas
transporte sino el antígeno puede perder
su eficacia veamos el informe
se trata de un desafío mayor el
transporte y la conservación de los
millones de vacunas que serán usadas en
la campaña de inoculación en francia
tienen movilizado a toda la cadena de
frío de la industria farmacéutica
nacional y es que en este país las dosis
más usadas necesitan permanecer a menos
70 o menos 80 grados celsius toda una
novedad en el mundo de la vacunas ya ha
dicho en ahora normalmente las vacunas
se conservan entre 2 y 8 grados celsius
y sobre todo no deben ser congeladas se
genera csa durán en cambio algunas
vacunas contra el cob it se conservan a
temperaturas bajo cero y no hay que
descongelar las hasta su uso para la
fase de liquidación en el hospital de
nantes al oeste de parís los
farmacéuticos de la institución están a
cargo de las condiciones en que se
guardan las dosis desde que salen del
congelador hasta que se inyectan a los
pacientes
y las vacunas no salen del refrigerador
hasta que tenemos a la persona frente a
nosotros lo que garantiza el buen uso de
cada dosis de acción pero los
especialistas de refrigeración en
francia consideran que lo que a ellos
les concierne la campaña de vacunación
tiene el éxito asegurado
el gran volumen de vacunas no es un
problema para nosotros estamos
logísticamente preparados tenemos que
tener confianza en la cadena logística y
la cadena de frío
lo cierto es que por ahora el volumen de
vacunas a conservar no ha representado
un desafío para francia con algunas
centenas de dosis aplicadas el país está
en retraso con respecto a sus vecinos
europeos
muchas gracias y ya con nosotros en
francés 24
[Música]